good morning believe nation today's
message is a value over to you Ryan
Blair you continued out dying in
people's eyes and then the more you do
that for a long enough period of time it
starts to have a bit of a ripple effect
well if you focus on that then you get
[ __ ] like this so but if you focus on
this you never get it and if you're
chasing money you'll be chasing your
whole life but if you're trying to
create value and the more value that you
create then you figure out an economic
engine around creating that value then
you can spend your whole life just doing
that you know and then in that
particular scenario money you know it
follows it doesn't leave the single most
important business principle that you
need to understand is that if you want
to make money you need to provide value
at the core of every successful
entrepreneur is the ability to provide
people value if you can't give value to
somebody you don't have the business the
question that you need to start asking
yourself is how can I bring more value
to the people around me you want to make
a lot of money provide a lot of value
you want to make a lot of money quickly
provide a lot of value quickly it's that
simple and you need to start thinking
how can I actually provide value to
people because too many entrepreneurs
start a business and they go under and
the reason was they didn't provide
enough value to their customers now Ryan
turns at a multi-level marketing or MLM
company and a lot of people don't have
success with MLM and some people ask is
MLM and scam MLM is just that it's just
a business model right there's nothing
inherently wrong with multi-level
marketing it's just that a lot of the
people who get into it never actually
use the product and so they're not
providing value
Salonen they join a company just because
I think they can make a lot of money and
if that's the reason why you go into
something you are going to fail I don't
need somebody at a multi-level marketing
company trying to sell me a protein
shake and tell me how it's gonna help my
workout recovery when they don't work
out and they don't drink that protein
shake you cannot sell a product that add
value to somebody's life when you don't
actually use it and passionately believe
in it now in terms of providing value I
just eat every day my youtube channel
right every time I post a video you guys
are leaving amazing comments telling me
how the video helped change you helped
give you different perspective and
that's the fuel for me - yes my youtube
channel allows me to make money but
that's not the reason why I do it
I do it because of the impact that it
has on me by researching these clips and
the impact that has on you because when
you guys write in to say thank you this
video helped change my life or thank you
I'm now looking at my business in a
different direction this gave me the
motivation if you go that that's fuel
for me that's value for you and value
for me too but if we look at your
products your services talk to your
customers are you getting that same
level of love are you providing that
same amount of value to them that they
are gushing about you telling their
friends about you feel so positive and
had their life impacted because of you
is that happening and if it's not that's
the reason why you are not as successful
as you could and should be you want to
get up here you want to make more money
you want to have a bigger impact you
want to play a bigger game
it starts with providing more value to
your customers and the people around you
that's the core that's a single most
important business principle that you
need to understand and if you're
struggling right now start asking
yourself the question how can I bring
people more about
so the question today today is how can
you bring your customers more value what
change can you make in your business or
your processes to bring the people who
care about what you're up to more value
what are you gonna do what change you're
gonna make big or small
I'm curious leave in the comments below
I'm gonna join the discussion thank you
guys so much for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event special